nous sommes amenés à travailler
quotidiennement dans la main mais cette
situation est à l'origine
malheureusement d'un mouvement social
donc je souhaitais poser tout simplement
la question non pas aux policiers mais
au représentant syndical dans le cadre
de ce scénario qui nous a été imposée à
scénario complètement de tronquer quelle
aurait été votre réaction en ça change
et en connaissant le déroulement de
cette manifestation avec autant de
violence automne et brio qu'entendez
vous par scénario quand on voit quand on
voit tout ce qu'il ya un an de richmond
c'est quand on voit les violences qui a
eu quel aurait été votre réaction vous
par rapport à ce qui s'est passé
est-ce que vous cautionnez ce qui a été
fait par les policiers aux têtes vous
expliquer alors lui dis qu'il ya un
piège en fait le démarrage n'a pas été
possible donc dès le départ lors de
l'ouverture du cortège de suite nous
avons été stoppés par les forces de
l'ordre
donc et gazés immédiatement ensuite
toute la manifestation était encadrée
aucune sortie possible et en fin de
course se retrouver devant un mur de
métal et la possibilité pour nous qui
venions d'un rendez vous avec le
ministre de pouvoir s'exprimer auprès de
nos collègues donc alors que la
manifestation avait été déclaré jusqu'à
18 heures ça a été impossible pour nous
alors vous dire que c'est pas parce
cette manifestation s'est pas passé
comme pour les autres corporations pour
les pompiers je pense qu'il ya toujours
un doute dans l'organisation d'une
manifestation de sapeurs pompiers en
sachant qu'ils n'ont pas affaire à des
infirmières et que les conditions de
dialogue n'existe plus donc il fallait
qu'on nous avions demandé aux mises de
l'intérieur de nous recevoir avant cette
manifestation pour être en capacité
d'annoncer à nos collègues
les quelques avancées possibles mais il
n'y a pas eu d'avancée donc d'annoncer
il a fallu attendre le rendez-vous à 14
heures doivent nous n'étions pas
présents lors du démarrage un fan de du
cortège dans que nous sommes arrivés en
fin de en fin de course sans pouvoir
c'est que nous exprimer au nom de
l'intersyndicale le cordage a suivi le
trafic était prévu le cortège a suivi le
tracé qui était prévu quelques quelques
collègues en sont sortis du cortège mais
sans commande de la part de
l'intersyndicale mais il n'y avait pas
de demande à ce que le cortège se se
dissipe ou quoi que ce soit non mais ça
générer ils sont sortis du trajet
initial non du tout une question c'est
une honte alors non mais en fait non à
la fin alors maintien ça c'est assez
intéressant ce que la question se posera
andré au coq est ce que vous puisque
vous dites alors plusieurs choix déjà un
petit propos liminaire je dois dire que
entre la police nationale et des
pompiers
on travaille main dans la marque
quotidiennement que je compte vraiment
y'a jamais il n'y a pas de problème d'
appât de souci ça se passe très bien
je comprends la colère des pompiers qui
légitime c'est vrai qu'ils sont victimes
d'agressions dans l'exercice de leur
métier de plus en plus + 30 % je crois
cette année dix agressions par jour des
agressions regret là il ya eu six balles
et j'ai collé des pompiers qui vont
travailler avec des gilets pare balles
ce n'est pas le cas c'est un scénario
par particulier le port du gilet ce que
je voudrais vous dire surtout c'est que
moi j'ai un constat vous savez on a eu
160 blessés parmi les forces de l'ordre
cette manifestation donc 5 de la 32ème
compagnie que je voudrais mettre à
l'honneur deux qui ont été opérés et
qu'elle soit sortie d'hôpital avec les
éclats de métal dans la jambe des
experts doutent jamais dans les yeux et
des collègues plus de 50 collègues qui
ont eu des soucis auditifs six de suite
à des tirs de mortiers et je vous ai
amené un petit document c'est là
communiqué de presse de la fédération
nationale des sapeurs-pompiers de france
le 29 janvier qui déclare donc c'est le
lendemain la violence pour se faire
entendre et contraire aux valeurs des
sapeurs pompiers de france
utiliser la violence pour se faire
entendre et totalement contraire aux
valeurs qui unissent les sapeurs
pompiers de france est de nature à
décrédibiliser le message de fermeté
demandé est attendue face à la
recrudescence des agressions dont sont
l'objet les sapeurs pompiers eux-mêmes
en intervention fédération nationale des
sapeurs-pompiers de france donc je n'ai
je n'ai vu aucun mortier sur le parcours
le bal des collègues étaient dans la
gueule des mortes hier je peux vous le
dk mortier si beaucoup et surtout au
cours de sa porte et nous les besoins de
la présidence j'ai des vidéos des vidéos
je voulais fait voir après l'émission il
ya pas dire que vous êtes en train de
dire que vous avez été attaqué monnet
était apte à présenter on a été attaqué
sur les 160 blessés sont parlés dans des
vidéos on a été littéralement à gré
alors c'est pas la majorité
le problème c'est que ça a dégénéré sur
le cours de vincennes où il y avait des
groupes qui voulaient sortir des
itinéraires prévus
voilà après la touline celle effectuée
le maintien de l'ordre pour que les
choses se passent bien
non bien énoncé pullman train de danser
le maintien du désordre des urgences et
cadets ont voulu sortir du cortège que
ça c'est qu'il ya eu un incident s'étant
produit s'exprime ses clients mais ce
communiqué alors d'abord cette
fédération n'est pas notre fédération
voilà non ça n'est pas notre fédération
aujourd'hui nous représentons les
sapeurs pompiers professionnels donc
cette fédération n'est pas la nôtre
donc elle est à la disposition de qui
l'ont tant en termes de communication
mais ça ne ce n'est pas la nôtre mais je
ne peux pas entendre que kylie à
l'utilisation de master 2 qui l'eût dit
c'est votre utilisation de mortier alors
ça veut dire que si les forces de police
étaient en présence de mortiers il
aurait dû donc se saisir de ces mortiers
pour qu'on puisse avoir des preuves de
l'utilisation de mortiers sur sur des
manifestations l'épreuve
vous pouvez reconnaître l'un et l'autre
que dans vos corporation respectives
il n'y ait des gens qui aient pu semer
la zizanie oui parce que globalement la
manifestation s'est bien passé mais il
faut à fait jouer au gault globalement
la manif est la scène s'est bien passé
il faut aussi le dire n'a pas été ça
durant toute la manifestation est aussi
des moments d'apaisement où ça s'est
bien passé il ya eu des moments très
chauds
dans ce moment très chaud est ce que
vous êtes capable de reconnaître tous
les deux mais plutôt que de vous
renvoyer un fauteur de trouble qu'il ya
à l'intérieur des corporations dans des
émeutes être des pompiers qui sont mal
comportés et peut-être des fonctions de
police qui ont manié le tournoi et le
coup de bâton un peu trop facilement
est ce que c'est possible que vous le
disiez vous pouvez attirer pro châble
les unes et les autres
et si la faute toujours des autres alors
engrais je ne dis pas que c'est la faute
des autres je dis simplement que je ne
suis pas là pour condamner mes collègues
moi je suis là pour condamner celui qui
commande pour que le déroulement de la
manifestation soit deux secondes dans
ces conditions voilà je ne suis pas là
pour condamner je suis représentant du
personnel qu'on a nous irons connaître
que parfois les gens qui liera rice et
bise parce que ce communiqué c'est qu'il
s'est passé quelque chose donc c'est
peut-être pas voilà c'est pas votre
votre syndicat c'est pas votre
fédération mais mine de rien si il ya eu
des tirs de mortiers sur les policiers
il ya eu des gens de troubles dont là je
n'ai jamais vu de mortier dans nos
manifestations
non utilisation l'utilisation virée
s'est montré digne l'utilisation ou
l'état de pétards de machines à pétard
ok mais ce ne sont pas des mortiers vous
savez vous que vous perdez pas vous
n'êtes pas accommoder pendant des
journées avec des simples pétards y eu
des tirs de mortiers des collègues ont
été victimes d'un deux collègues ont été
5 avec moitié hospitalisés je peux vous
le dire mais je suis allé au pourquoi on
n'a pas su ça dans les médias parce que
ça c'est sorti nulle part mais non là on
l'apprend ce soir avec ses communiqués
est-ce que j'étais pas des personnes qui
n'étaient pas des pompiers l'intérieur à
l'eau parce que ça c'est vrai que ça
s'est sorti de sa femme les prestations
il y avait non pas malheureusement
peut-être l'âge et médine hypothèse
puisque on n'a pas de preuve de rien du
tout mais est ce qu'ils auraient pas été
victimes des tirs de grenade qu'ils ont
eux mêmes lancé par centrale pour le
coup ça fait mal au début mais en
général on tire pas dessus général
alors quand il ya des grenades qui se
balade devant ce mur
revoilà ça m'étonnerait pas que qui est
déjà possible selon la police grenade
pas enfin web au travers d'un portrait
express entre repos dans le commandement
qui a été donné aux forces de l'ordre
parce que femme il faut le pompier ça me
dire qu'ils en voulaient aux
commandements peut-être plus que et au
personnel d'exécution qui était cet
arrêt est ce que le commandement
aujourd'hui vous en tant que
syndicaliste pompiers qui avaient été
pompés de terrain vous nous remettez en
cause est ce que les ordres sont claires
est ce que parfois on nous a manqué un
peu au carton alors les angles sont les
faits des ans
les ordres sont beaucoup plus claire
qu'il n'était il ya deux ans regardez
les scénarios qu'on a eue lors des
manifestations du 1er au 8 décembre 2018
et 26 mars 2019 ou là il y avait une
lenteur des ordres donnés il y avait
beaucoup de collègues livrés à eux mêmes
et effectivement ça a donné
malheureusement toutes ses magasins
saccagés et cetera où on avait un manque
de réactivité
ensuite il a changé maintenant
l'objectif c'est action réaction
notamment avec la fameuse utilisation
des braves vous savez les brigades de
répression anti lente
les motos d'ailleurs à en parler parce
que ça s'est fait à l'idée est bonne
mais ça s'est fait en toute
précipitation et ses collègues des
braves encore aujourd'hui
sont complètement démotivée parce qu'on
l'aimé on les fait monter au créneau à
chaque fois pour les manifestations tous
les week-ends ils ont très peu
d'effectifs et la spécialité moto les
collègues sont en train de les quitter
carrément dégoûté
donc là dessus c'est encore une légende
urbaine que devenir n'y a pas d'heure du
préfet j'ai l'impression monsieur que
vous dites que il ya eu un traquenard de
prévu et s'est surtout dit on dresser ce
comment vous expliquer ce que sur tout
le parcours vous gaziers sur tout le
parcours
surtout le parquet comment vous
expliquez que qu'un illuminé montrent
enfin s'amuser à gravir le mur de
dassier se pose sur votre canne en eau
et que un de vos collègues du tir en
pleine tête avec le ldb
comment vous l'expliquez ceci pourquoi
alors vu les images d'avant ou violences
j'ai vu des images d'avant qui n'avait
pas vu ça c'est malheureusement certains
de vos collègues qui ont essayé de deux
d'arracher ces dernières la rentrée dans
le ferry on va voir on va voir les
images
regardez vous avez regardé les images
dont parle andré il faut se poser des
questions ou des vidéos
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
alors on a fait de la peine car
exactement quand reprendre et même ils
obtenaient les revendications
moi j'ai envie de ça mon gré andré et
rocco comment ça va se passer maintenant
comment ça va se passer maintenant entre
la police et les pompiers parce que on a
tous une crainte on se dit peut-être ça
va être maintenant la guerre entre la
police et les pompiers alors qu'ils
doivent travailler main dans la main
est ce que vous êtes parler est ce qu'il
ya eu ensuite un voilà est-ce que vous
il ya eu voilà dialogue entre les
policiers entre les syndicats de
pompiers pour dire voilà comment on va
faire et comment on va avancer mayer
alors que nous pas quoi voilà est-ce
qu'elle la rancune ou pas il a raison
gagne parce que là c'est important
encombré
non non je ne suis pas condamner la
majorité des policiers c'est c'est comme
dans nos forces en présence je vois là
je ne condamne pas les forces de police
nous sommes nous sommes continuellement
à travailler ensemble
le scénario est différent puisque c'est
sécuriser le territoire et nous c'est
sauver et sauver les sauver les vies
exactement que ensuite on a un problème
c'est qui est évident c'est la prise en
compte de nos revendications majeures
bien sûr c'est qu'aujourd'hui nous ne
sommes plus en capacité d'assurer nos
missions
ça n'est plus possible pour nous toutes
les missions régaliennes qui devrait
être assuré normalement par les services
de l'état ne le sont plus le plus bel
exemple ce sont les forces de police les
forces de police qui devrait prendre en
charge les personnes ivres sur la voie
publique les verbaliser les placer en
cellule de dégrisement qu'ils soient
visités par médecins ne le font pas ils
donc
il modifie le statut de la personne qui
ivre le désigne comme un personnes pris
d'un malaise pour ne pas le prendre en
charge c'est à nous de le prendre en
charge de venir encombrer les services
des urgences ça n'est plus possible pour
nos locaux juste vous dire ce que ce que
vous dites est ce que vous quand même
vous considérez que c'est un petit
groupe de pompiers qui ont été violents
et pas tous les pompiers parce qu'on
dirait qu'en fait tout à coup tout les
pompiers de manifestations aurait été
violent mais c'est un groupuscule comme
dans beaucoup de manifestations jeu va
lancer un petit groupe qui a été violent
mais il ya plein de pompiers qui ont
manifesté le ps va ne s'est pas la
police contre les pompiers c'est un
groupe sacyr talent s'est senti agressé
ou je ne sais pas de ce que nous dit
andré
agressé du début à la fin de la
manifestation c'est ce que vous avancez
ce qu'il est en train de lire os qu est
ce que vous pouvez répondre à la
question de nombriliste ce que vient de
dire andré alors sur ce problème là
effectivement qui relate vers l'avenue
qui se pense qu'on avait les relais vous
savez que haut niveau il ya des missions
sont faites par des objectifs
il n'y a plus d'effet qu'à vous vous
mettez le doigt sur un point sensible
c'est que à force de mobiliser la
ressource sur le maintien de l'ordre
parce que je vous dit vous savez combien
de manifestations par an en france non
dit cinq mineurs d'accord plus de 5000
ce qui veut dire qu'on mobilise toute la
ressource pour le maintien de l'ordre
des deux tiers déséquilibre au co sur le
maintien de l'ordre les samedis ne sont
pas des spécialistes de maintien de
l'ordre exactement je suis fier d'aider
j'allais me liront mais là le préfet de
police de paris mais toute la ressource
à contribution et ce qui fait que
malheureusement il ya le principe de les
basques où ni quand il y a des choses
qu'on ne peut plus faire qu'on ne peut
pas faire parce qu'on est mobilisés mais
c'est vrai que c'est pour ça qu'on a des
statistiques sur la hausse de la
délinquance notamment sur la hausse des
cambriolages parce que malheureusement
ans pendant et depuis de nombreux mois
la ressource est mobilisé par rapport
aux émaux en matière de langue beaucoup
vous dit quelque chose qui est tout beau
temps de faire de nos services publics
c'est une vraie question est est ce que
c'est toujours peau de chagrin et cissé
peau de chagrin effectivement un moment
donné à des missions qu'on peut plus
assumer exactement vous devez aller sur
le terrain qu'ils peuvent h mais c'est
pareil pour l'hôpital public on le voit
ça craquait de partout et nous dans
l'émission n'a reçu des gens qui sont en
souffrance et qui sont des représentants
du service public où il incarnait encore
ce soir tous les deux mais qui alors ne
pas répondre à la souffrance humaine
mais je finis mon cher nos anciens qui
souffrent qui mental qui n'ont pas de
qui les accompagnent nous n'avons plus
effectif on nous demande d'assurer
toutes les missions régaliennes de
remplacer les ambulanciers ça n'est plus
possible et personne ne veut vendre pas
lent le service public est en souffrance
et personne ne veut l'entendre
j'ai une question à une question de
laurence aiea à roko mais se contente au
moi je sais que enfin on l'a tous dit la
haine anti-flic c'est un phénomène
terrible qui se propage de manière très
forte d'ailleurs par déjà les des gens
qui manifestent qui disent on veut plus
de la police à mort la police
c'est assez terrible et vous suicidez
vous
les médias aussi qui parfois ne montre
pas tout je veux pas critiquer les
médias parce que c'est totalement démago
mais c'est vrai que parfois il ya des
vidéos qui tournent et qui sont
totalement à charge et on voit pas
l'ensemble du contexte
et enfin c'est surtout ce que je trouve
le plus grave c'est que des responsables
politiques et notamment de la france
insoumis très clairement se sont
positionnés depuis des mois pour dire
que la police était une milice ministre
il l'a dit parce que tu pensé un jour
voir sa saison mais ce coup mais olivier
qui s'attaque à me sortir de mon copain
même par l'onf et on a dit que la télé
me dit laeticia est ce que est ce que
met à mal la place saint melaine restons
sur le sujet alors le sujet et comme
dirait qu'on mixtes ont ce qu'on a là
sous les yeux non à quel nom marié
économie alors que je ne lui parle pas
raquel garrido avait continué donc
monsieur mélenchon à lundi que la police
était une milice aux ordres de l'état je
suis pourtant pas la porte parole de
monsieur mais l'enjeu c'est pour ça les
deux d'ailleurs bolas exactement on se
demande un peu les essais de façon des
milk est inutilement avec des locales en
compte un sujet est suffisamment je
verrai si elle a posé sa question
tu sais la profession qui dirait ma
question à l'esma la même si elle te
dérange nous la tombe monsieur contente
hoogan base avait entendu que monsieur
mélenchon a traité de milice de barbares
propos qui ont été cautionnés et
j'imagine que vous avez été touchés vous
je pense que de savoir que des
personnalités politiques des
responsables politiques qui portent une
voix qui a entendu par de nombreuses
personnes puissent comme ça remettre en
cause l'ordre républicain et votre
travail
qu'est ce que vous auriez envie de dire
aujourd'hui quel est votre colère
qu'est-ce que vous aurez envie de dire
aujourd'hui à monsieur mélenchon par
exemple écouter sur monsieur mélenchon
nous on a été très choqué par lorsqu'il
a dit que les policiers étaient des
barbares la police et barbare d'ailleurs
c'était un il avait dit que c'était une
conversation privée
mais ce qui lui a pas échappé c'est qu'
avec l'amant l'air de l'anneau de la une
presse qui filmait tout ça et ça s'est
retrouvée sur les réseaux sociaux
preview on a la vidéo regardez regardez
ça m'enlève mon à la vivre ça se dit pas
qu'on va regarder
maintenant il
petacchi
les parents
durand alors après après vous savez ce
que c'est le ministre fait pas
l'impression que la police française
c'est la gestapo ou une mini savez la
police qui tue c'est pas police
française c'est plutôt les amis
sandiniste et d'honneur de monsieur
mélenchon voilà alors moi j'ai envie
d'en girardon messti scaligero par
exemple elles ont les breaks douanes
ils sont pas morts oka caracas monsieur
contente oh oui vous permettez d'accord
et je pense franchement que quand un
témoin d'une manifestation vient
exprimer la peur physique qui ressent
désormais d'aller manifester
bah c'est ce qu'on ressent tout se
mélange dans les lieux d'art et moi je
vais manifester et aujourd'hui je suis
une maman de trois enfants j'ai 45 ans
et j'ai peur quand j'ai manifesté dans
ma vie si on peut aussi en se levant le
matin là parce que les qu'en est il
quand il ya des hommes qui seront
éborgné des mains arrachées et que
d'autres hommes regardent ça avec un
défaut total et absolu d'empathie
pardon mais le terme de barbarie
peut-être qu'ici ça choque dans les
salons et dans les plateaux télé mais
laissez-moi vous dire qu'à la maison
les gens ils savent très bien de quoi on
parle oui il faut élever duchaussoy le
nom circule herman insensible pour
regarder généraux burgess dans l'ain qui
reste pour lui dire que tout ça est
normal de la même façon que depuis tout
à l'heure on essaie de vous faire
comprendre que que nous fait d'avoir
deux vous avez pris physiquement
de cette façon là aux pompiers ça remet
en cause quelque chose de fondamental de
notre république et vous êtes là à faire
comme si c'était une tâche
administrative
[Applaudissements]
si vous permettez je ne ferai pas de
procès d'intention aux policiers et aux
gendarmes mobiles maintenant quelques
années c'est bien procès d'un camion
pompier à ceux qui commandent et au
défaut de dialogue social
outré par ce gouvernement et ggg j'ai
compris que vous parliez de haine de
tout à l'heure mais il n'y a pas de
haine des pompiers vis-à-vis des voilà
que les choses soient claires dans
l'expression de cette manifestation
il n'y a pas de haine il ya un
ras-le-bol qui s'est généralisé il ya
une incompréhension qui est profonde
nous sommes malgré nous sommes malmenés
nous sommes malmenés parce que nous ne
sommes plus en capacité d'assurer nos
missions nous sommes usés
tout comme les forces de police lors
urgent antiste comme tous les services
publics en général et nous n'y avons
plus d'un
dans des moyens pour réussir à assurer
nos missions de service public de
secours mais nous pouvons vous avez vous
obtenu non non non tout simplement parce
que nous sommes dans une partie de ping
pong entre armand et nos employeurs
spécial des retraites je pense que je
suis un peu je pense que je suis au
quotidien pour tous répondaient pas ce
qu'on va coopérer à tout ce que j'aimais
tout le monde d'accord vous savez
monsieur ce que vous dites
on est dans une crise politique c'est
pas la police et la gendarmerie de la
dénouer
mais c'est aux politiques mais voilà et
ça je le dis à chaque fois sur les
plateaux dégradation du climat social
dans ce pays toutes les professions une
convergence des luttes qu on peut voir
aussi c'est vrai que c'est une réalité
et c'est vrai que la colère est
mobilisatrice et on n'en finit pas de
manifestation le policier lorsqu'il va
faire son maintien de l'ordre
le matin ce qui veut lui aussi rentré
entier chez lui voit sa femme et ses
enfants parce que les dossiers les plus
folles qui va les voir travailler
qu'avec des moyens et faire leur mission
ne seront pas les 25 % l'augmentation de
notre ami de feu qui nous fera sortir de
ce de ce sommet de ceux de ces troubles
elle n'a jamais su ça n'est pas l'argent
qui réussira à réduire les espaces dans
l'organisation de notre service